republicans probably hold the senate and
pick up seats in the house
the election carries on into wednesday
and apparently far beyond
and we analyze what everyone yes every
single human
got wrong i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the bench shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn surf the web with peace of
mind sign up now at expressvpn.com we'll
get to all the chaos and it is this is
the most chaotic day
in american political history or at
least that i can remember
okay this is more chaotic than 2000 it
is just it is it is a bleep show it is a
bleep show out there
there are a bevy of states that are too
close to call we are the morning
after the election there's still a bevy
of states that are too close to call
arizona
nevada wisconsin michigan pennsylvania
all too close to call georgia might be
in that list
we still don't know who the president is
going to be we don't know
whether this is going to come down to
voting irregularities and what the voter
rules actually are in states like
pennsylvania or michigan
or wisconsin it is an absolute utter
mess only one thing is perfectly clear
everybody in the polling industry needs
to learn to code they need to learn to
code
except for robert kehley over at
trafalgar every single other human
in the polling industry needs to
immediately be put to work digging
ditches so they can meet an actual human
outside of new york and l.a the polling
areas here were so bad we're going to
get to all of this
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that the market
is not a big fan of uncertainty the
market does not love uncertainty
i can't think of any more uncertain time
and unsettled time than this has been
over the course of the last year
that's why it's worthwhile diversifying
at least a little bit into precious
metals you should diversify a portion of
your savings into gold or silver
precious metals are perhaps the greatest
hedge against uncertainty and the
weakening value of the dollar birch gold
group it's the company i recommend to
buy gold and silver from
i buy gold and you should as well birch
gold will help you legally convert an
eligible ira or 401k into a precious
metals ira
or you can just buy gold or silver to
lock in your personal safe text ben
247 4747 get a free information kit on
diversifying into gold
and then call birch gold these guys are
the best that's why i've been endorsing
them for years on end at this point they
have an a plus rating with the better
business bureau countless five star
reviews give them a call get all the
information
ask all of your questions and then when
you're ready to invest do it with the
people over at birch gold text ben
to 47 47 47 to get started text ben 247
47 47 open a precious metals ira secure
your savings today again
text ben to 47 47 47
to get started okay so i'm just gonna
tell you right up front i'm exhausted
i'm exhausted we're up super late last
night
12 hours of broadcasting time last night
and this thing is far from done
it is not it is not over okay this is
not over by any stretch of
the imagination so here is the latest
the trump team
bill stephen trump's campaign manager he
says that wisconsin is a tight race and
recount territory it is indeed extremely
close
right now the vote count in wisconsin
says about 97
in and uh joe biden has a 0.6 percent
lead
in wisconsin he's up by about 20 000
votes
in wisconsin and they're apparently
still another hundred thousand votes
still left to be counted in wisconsin as
of this morning so that is where things
stand right now
okay then you move on over to
pennsylvania trump right now
pennsylvania is taking its sweet
damn time for all the talk about florida
by the way being you know florida man
and crazy state florida
worked beautifully florida reported its
vote totals and we were done by early in
the evening with florida we'll get to
florida in a second because it shows
some real pathways forward for the
republican party in the future and some
real
shortcomings for the democratic party
that are quite delicious in a variety of
ways
pennsylvania trump right now is up about
10 points in pennsylvania
which is about 534 000 votes there's
still 1.6 million votes out there to be
totaled those are supposed to break
heavily democrats it's going to be
extremely
close in pennsylvania north carolina
trump is likely to win
michigan is really really close like
separated by
12 000 votes at this point biden up 0.2
points
0.2 still about half a million votes to
be counted in michigan
trump looks like he is going to finish
off georgia so there's a lot of doubt
last night as to whether trump was
actually going to win georgia it started
off as
likely trump then it moved to lean trump
then it moved to toss-up and now it's
back to
likely trump at this point arizona is a
state that is absolutely chaotic arizona
was called very early on
in the night by fox news they insisted
that they were right and now there's new
information suggesting that
maybe there are a bunch of maybe there
are a bunch of votes outstanding in
arizona so this is just an
absolute mess it's an absolute mess the
trump campaign nevada is extremely tight
in fact nevada is only about eight
thousand to ten thousand votes apart and
nevada just decided they're not going to
announce any new vote totals until
tomorrow which is
all unconscionable and guys fix your
election systems seriously
it doesn't mean that fraud is happening
but fix your damn election systems
so stephen says michigan they're
confident in a pathway that includes
the state nevada they're claiming
victory possible by 5 500 votes
and they're projecting optimism about
georgia and pennsylvania
as well so recounts don't as far as
wisconsin recounts don't normally
reverse 20 000 vote gaps they don't
usually it'll shift a couple hundred
votes either way
in florida for example george w bush and
al gore we had months of recounting and
it only shifted a couple hundred votes
in
al gore's direction so shifting tens of
thousands of votes on the basis of a
recount
is fairly unlikely trump campaign
advisers believe that arizona might
still
be in reach for president trump on the
regular account because they're still
counting election day
voters so trump could theoretically win
at nevada and arizona and that would put
him over the top
if trump takes nevada and does not win
arizona but wins pennsylvania
then he could still be over the top so
this thing is not over yet and this is
putting aside the possibility of
lawsuits this is putting aside the
possibility of irregularities being
found
right so in other words everything is a
mess everything is an absolute mess
there are only a few things that are
absolutely clear at this point in time
one is that the polls are damned garbage
so i've been bringing the polls
consistently okay i'm bringing the polls
because i don't like operating in the
absence of data
my bias my bias in favor of data turns
out to be a bias in favor of crap
because the data here was crap okay the
data here was garbagio
and it was really garbagio on the
national level
the final real clear politics polling
average spread on this election
had joe biden up seven points nationally
seven points nationally
right now in the national vote count
total joe biden is up
by less than two points nationally less
than two
is it just over 50 and trump is at just
over 48 percent
okay that is not seven points it is
certainly not ten points
i mean i'm just going to read you some
of the polls that were being trotted out
the day before the election
the economist yougov had biden up 10
points ten
ibd tipp had biden up four and that was
the most optimistic poll
for trump reuters had biden up seven
cnbc
had biden up ten quinnipiac had biden up
11 nbc news wall street journal had
biden up 10.
okay the gap is two two when you blow it
that badly on the national polling
no one should ever trust you again all
these jackasses need to learn to code
like
right now and yeah incompetence bothers
me it really really does
okay how about the battleground states
so the battleground states were fairly
wildly off as well
in the battleground states in the real
clear politics polling average which was
more favorable to trump than for example
the 538 polling average
in the real clear politics polling
average they had trump down in flora by
0.9
trump will end up winning that state by
three percent so not particularly close
in florida once again they blew it in
florida
in north carolina the real club politics
pulling average had trump up by
0.2 right now north carolina
with 95 reporting has trump up by about
two points 1.5
two points the real clear politics
polling average
in arizona had biden winning that state
slim
it looks like that may hold up in
wisconsin here's a
massive polling error in wisconsin in
wisconsin the real clear politics
polling average had biden up nearly
seven
points in wisconsin nearly seven in
wisconsin right now
biden is up by less than a point in
wisconsin he's up by about 20
000 votes total in wisconsin that is a
six point polling error in florida you
are looking at a five-point polling
error in the national
numbers you are looking at a minimum
five-point polling error in many of
these polls in eight or nine-point
polling error
polling is chicken and trail reading
these people don't know what the hell
they are doing
they don't know how to poll for trump's
coalition they don't know how to poll
people who are not college-educated
white people they don't know how to poll
people who are not picking up the phone
all of your questions about polls were
totally justified now to be fair to
myself i did say i am skeptical
that it is as far apart as the polls
were suggesting and i did say yesterday
that trump could easily win this thing
without the polls being totally wrong on
the state level
and that's true all of these margin of
error states many of them remained
margin of error
okay but something is deeply wrong in
the polling industry
something is deeply wrong in our media
industry they were suggesting that joe
biden could hide in his basement and run
away with this thing this is not a
runaway under any circumstances
not only is it not a runaway these
aren't even the worst polling errors the
worst polling errors are not
on the heavily pulled trump pad and race
the worst polling errors
were all of the polling errors in the
senate there they just blew it
and i will pat myself on the back for my
prediction on the senate i did say i
thought that republicans
would likely hold the senate so
a mess for pollsters today an absolute
mess and a big night for republicans by
the way
if you're a republican regardless of how
this turns out with trump because that's
still up in the air and he could still
win this thing depending on
how those late votes are counted
depending on whether there are lawsuits
right this is still very much up in the
air
regardless of that if you're a
republican or a conservative you should
feel very good moving forward this was
supposed to be a year like 2018 where
democrats
walked away with this thing or it was a
blue title wave washing away on its path
where joe biden was going to win by 10
points nationally he was going to carry
350 electoral votes where democrats were
going to walk away with the senate
where they were going to then nuke the
filibuster and then use it to cram
through states
and cram through court packing none of
that's going to happen now
senator mitch mcconnell is going to be
in charge of the senate majority in all
likelihood
at this point which is a devastating
blow to the democrats
and old slo joe biden winning what may
be the narrowest electoral college
victory in american history
right if if it turns out that trump wins
georgia
and he wins pennsylvania and biden wins
all of the others
the election gap is something like 270
to 268.
okay that is as close as as it is
possible to get okay that is not
a massive mandate for a huge world
beating change and
joe biden is old and daughtering andrew
biden can't hold a thought in his head
and he's going to face a fractious
coalition
so if you're a conservative regardless
of what happens going forward if you
just stop time at this moment before we
even know what happens in the
presidential race last night was a very
very good night
for republicans and demonstrates full
scale that our media are garbage and
need to be replaced forth with
like need to be fully replaced forth
with we'll get you more of that in just
one second
first you've hired me to you've heard me
talk about how important it is to have a
vpn
now that a lot of you are working from
home it's even more important to choose
a vpn you trust now
i like to do research on my sponsors i
only recommend brands to my listeners i
believe in and use myself
as generally speaking i can say with
full confidence expressvpn is the best
vpn on the market here's why number one
expressvpn doesn't log your data lots of
really cheap or free vpns make money by
selling your data to ad companies
expressvpn developed a technology called
trusted server that makes it impossible
for their servers to log any of your
info number two
speed i've tried a lot of vpns in the
past many slow your connection down or
make your device sluggish
i've been using expressvpn for a long
time and my internet speeds are blazing
fast which is necessary i run an
internet company
something else that really sets express
vpn apart it's easy to use
unlike other vpns you don't have to
input or program anything you just fire
up that app you click one button and you
now connect it is so easy even your
grandparents
can use it so go protect yourself right
now with the vpn i use and trust
use my link at expressvpn.com today get
an extra three months free on a one year
package that's expressvpn.com once more
expr essvpn.com ben to make sure
that your internet activity is protected
expressvpn.com
ben use that slash ben get an extra
three months free on a one year package
okay
so how badly were the
were the pollsters off on the senate
they were even worse
than they were with regard to the to the
republican and democratic presidential
contest
on the senate we were assured that cal
cunningham was going to win in north
carolina he did not
we were told that south carolina was a
toss-up we were told that south carolina
was a toss-up
not only was it not a toss-up lindsey
graham blew out
blew out his opponent in that race
by leaps and bounds like 13 points
blowout huge huge blowout okay we were
told
that amy mcgrath versus senator mitch
mcconnell that that was a somewhat
competitive race
not even close not even remotely close
mitch mcconnell blew
them out blew them out the fact is
democrats spent
200 million dollars trying to oust
tom tillis in north carolina what was
that i'm sorry not even till us
they spent 200 million dollars trying to
oust lindsey graham in south carolina
and mitch mcconnell in kentucky and they
got blown the f out
in both of those races and the posters
were telling us that both were
competitive particularly that south
carolina race
okay republicans pulled out the victory
in iowa that was supposed to be a
democratic victory for most of the race
republicans pulled out the victory in
montana republicans pull out the victory
in north carolina that was supposed to
be a democratic win
republicans are going to win both of the
seats in georgia
okay republicans are going to lose that
seat in all likelihood martha mcsally in
arizona they're going to lose corey
gardner in colorado if that's what you
got for your lincoln project griff money
gang
well good luck to you the ap reports
hopes fading for senate control
democrats had a disappointing election
night as republicans swatted down an
onslaught of challengers and fought to
retain their fragile majority
it was a jarring outcome for democrats
words that he loved to hear who had
devised an expanded political math
eager to provide a backstop against
president trump and his party's grip on
the senate
the race has attracted an unprecedented
outpouring of small dollar donations
from americans
apparently voting with their pocket
books to propel long-shot challenges
however they lost a seat in alabama and
then republicans held their own in one
race after another south carolina iowa
texas
kansas and montana lindsey graham
tweeted out you wasted a lot of money
he said this is the worst return on
investment in the history of american
politics because he defeated
jamie harrison by double digits after
they dumped 100 million dollars
into that campaign it looks very much as
though
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
stays the senate majority leader john
cornyn in texas retains his seat
joni ernst defeats teresa greenfield
that was seen as a toss-up
it looks like in maine susan collins is
going to retain hersey in fact susan
collins
was it was dancing over the course of
the evening because republicans
held her seat here was susan collins
getting jiggy with it last night in
maine
i mean i'm not a huge susan collins fan
but i will say that susan collins
holding that seat is a massive
massive thing there's a big difference
between a 50 50 cent in which kamala
harris
casts the the deciding vote if indeed
biden pulls out the election
and a republican majority in the senate
so this is this is all good news for
republicans very very good news for
republicans and republicans based on the
supposed data had no right to expect any
of that good news to materialize
not just that progressive candidates got
skunked throughout the country so in
heavy blue districts they won right aoc
won re-election that is not a shock
the honorable alexander ocasio-cortez
democrat of twitch of course she's going
to win re-election she's in a d plus 1
million district
but there are a bunch of progressive
house candidates who are badly lagging
in closely contested races according to
josh kraushauer over at national journal
he cites four separate races in which
members of the justice democrats
or at least adjunct members lost their
races last night it turns out americans
are just not all that interested in that
kind of garbage outside of brooklyn
so republicans are gonna pick up
somewhere in all likelihood between five
and ten house seats
republicans are gonna retain the senate
which brings us back to the presidential
race itself
so the pollsters got this thing wildly
wrong why did they get it wildly wrong
because they literally don't understand
trump's coalition because nobody really
understands trump's coalition so i'm
going to give you some exit poll numbers
these are astonishing
truly astonishing because they do not
fit the democratic narrative
at all one iota if one narrative should
have died
a gruesome death last night it was the
narrative of the woke
it was the narrative of the woke scolds
that simply shouting racist at everybody
means that you're going to be able to
create a really durable minority
coalition to defeat
the supposed racist white silent
majority
right that narrative bit the dust last
night and it bit it incredibly hard
the media bit the dust last night they
spent four years declaring that donald
trump is an abject racist that he's a
bigot
that anybody who votes for him is a
racist and a bigot
and americans not only showed up on mass
to vote for for president trump i mean
in huge
huge numbers there's a record turnout
year this is the biggest turnout year in
american politics since 1900
okay normally you would think right
because of that conventional wisdom
mythos
that big turnout helps democrats it did
not last night it was a huge turnout
year
and guess what even if joe biden wins
it's going to be by the thinnest of
hairs
by the thinnest of hairs on that balding
pate he is going to win the election if
he wins at all
that is where things currently stand and
what's amazing is the coalition that
trump put together here
okay trump's coalition is the future of
the republican party
trump's coalition is fascinating it's
fascinating because what we are watching
is a rebuke to the woke mentality that
demography is destiny
the demographics are destiny that all
you have to do is call republicans
racist and you can cobble together a
huge super majority
of hispanics and blacks and asians and
then you can just
replicate the obama coalition once again
the obama coalition only works for
barack obama because barack obama's
unique candidate
he was the outlier barack obama is not
the new democratic party barack obama
is not the future pathway for the
democratic party barack obama's unique
candidate at a unique time
the reality i mean these exit poll
numbers are going to blow your mind
while democrats continue to maintain
that it's just that half of americans
are racist that's why trump did so well
last night regardless of final outcome
while they maintain that the reality is
far different if trump loses it's
becoming
it's going to be because he lost a share
of white men
not kidding not kidding these exit poll
numbers
are a ringing rebuke to everybody in the
media who thought that they had any fix
on this election because
after 2016 they said oh well you know
maybe we'll go out into the sticks and
we'll talk to some of these trump
supporters
and it was though they were steve irwin
exploring the wilds
and it turns out they didn't understand
trump supporters they didn't understand
nearly anything about how politics works
in the country
they intellectualized their way into
believing that if they went with the
intersectional coalition it was going to
carry them to victory
and it absolutely did not it was a
horrible night for intersectionality
last night it was a horrible night for
the woke
which is a great night for the country
we're going to get some more of that in
just one second first
let us talk about a good night's rest so
needless to say i did not get much rest
last night there are two reasons for
that
one there was an election last night and
that was really damn stressful and it is
still very very stressful too
i wasn't in my bed i wasn't in my helix
sleep bedroom a bed i need my helix
sleep mattress because it was made for
me
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences
to the perfect mattress for you whether
you're a side sleeper or a hot sleeper
whether you like a plush or from bed
with helix there's no more confusion and
no more compromising helix sleep is
rated the number one mattress by gq and
wired magazine cnn and called it the
most comfortable mattress they've ever
slept on
just head on over to helixleep.com take
their two minutes sleep quiz they will
match you to a customized mattress
that'll give you
the best sleep of your life they even
have a 10-year warranty you get to try
out for 100 nights at risk free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it
but you're going to because they made it
just for you it is that comfortable my
wife and i have one
it is like sleeping on a cloud it's
great helix is offering up to 200 bucks
off all
mattress orders for our listeners right
now get up to 200 bucks off at
helixsleep.com
that is helixsleep.com go check them out
right now
helixsleep.com ben
alrighty so here are some of the numbers
from the exit polls and again
these are absolutely stunning these are
astonishing numbers from the exit polls
so trump won men this is the new york
times exit polling
trump won man 49 48 he lost women by 13.
okay that was perfectly predictable that
was the only predictable part of the
night
he won 57 percent of the white vote
versus 42
for joe biden among black americans
there was some early data that suggested
that he may have won in places like
florida up to 14 or 15
of the black vote even by the new york
times estimate
he won 12 of the black vote okay last
time around he went i believe seven
percent of the black vote so he
radically improved his showing
among black americans he radically
improves his showing among hispanic
americans he won 32 percent
of the hispanic vote he won 31
of the asian vote okay these are these
are not numbers
that the media were even close to
expecting right he improved his share
with black men black women he improved
his share
with elderly americans i'm sorry
he didn't improve a share of elderly
americans but he held them he improved
his share with virtually every
demographic subgroup in the united
states with the exception
of white men i'm not joking that is a
thing that happened last night
okay and maybe what that says is that
americans want to be campaigned to as
individuals
here's the thing about trump he cuts
through this group identity crap
because everybody has an individual
opinion of donald trump nobody
has the image of donald trump that is
written on the wall by the media about
trump
i've been very critical of trump's use
of twitter i'm very critical of some of
the things that i think trump has said
that are wrong
but it is absolutely true that he has a
unique connection with american voters
because he is so prominent because
everybody knew who donald trump was
before he ran it made it very difficult
for the media ever
to box him in or paint him as exactly
what they wanted him to be
and this is reflected in a lot of these
exit polling results
i mean these you people should feel
astonished by this
they should feel shocked by this and
they should feel really optimistic about
all of this
because what this means is that the
demographic stranglehold that we were
told democrats have on hispanic voters
does not exist the democratic
stranglehold that supposedly had on
black voters
that has been wildly overrated these
exit polls
are evidence that republicans can in
fact make
head that they can make ground with
particular demographic groups that
supposedly
they had forgotten about i mean this is
this is amazing amazing stuff and it
came
from donald trump right the guy who they
were calling a wild racist
for years on end there are a lot of
folks on the right mary catherine ham
had
a good tweet last night she said i
always thought republicans could put
together a multiracial coalition i just
didn't think trump would be the one to
do it but
in many ways he was the one to do it
specifically because he is donald trump
and because people have very specific
opinions on him
as a human being and he cannot simply be
mocked up as
generic republican racist by democrats
okay here is so matt bruning uh of a
people
policy project he he got a hold of some
edison exit polling here's what it
showed
it showed that trump's share of support
among white men dipped five percent
among white women it increased by two
percent among black men it increased by
four percent among black women
it increased by four percent according
to the exit polling for medicine
trump won 17 of black men 17
of black men if you told me before the
election that trump went 17 of black men
and 35
of latino men you'd think okay this guy
wins a clear
re-elect victory he just lost a little
bit in the white male category and
that's a very very large category in the
united states
so he made headway with latino men with
latino women with black men with black
women
with other so that would include asian
americans and 36 percent of the vote
with the other group in the united
states and that that is an amazing
amazing and
that bodes so well for the future of the
country honestly that's the thing that
makes me most optimistic from last night
because what that says is that the
intersectional bullcrap that we have all
been fed that we ought to think of each
other in terms of group identity it is a
lie
it is a lie and you can fight back
against that lie and donald trump
deserves full credit for fighting back
against that lie for not caving to the
lie that he is a racist
for not caving to the idea that he has
to be defined by the media for not
accepting
the premise of all of their questions
that america is a racist and terrible
place that you can win
minority voters while saying that
america is a wonderful place that is not
a black lives matter hellscape that is
an amazing amazing thing and it bodes
really well for the future of the
republican party i want to point out
specifically in just one second
what happened last night in florida
because florida
is the future of the republican party my
new home state wonderful wonderful state
we'll talk about that in just one second
first let us talk about getting in shape
so over the course of this pandemic a
lot of people gain some weight because
you're home a lot and that meant some
stress eating and all the rest
well one thing you have to change if you
actually want to change weight is your
habit
it really isn't so much about diets
because people go on diets and they go
off diets it really is about changing
how you think about health
how you think about exercise how you
think about what kind of food you put in
your body and this is where nume
comes in noom is the habit changing
solution that helps users learn to
develop a new relationship with food
through personalized courses
based in psychology nume teaches you why
you do the things you do and empowers
you with the tools you need to break bad
habits and replace them with better ones
newman's a diet it's a healthy easy to
stick to way of life
pneuma has one of the biggest most
accurate food databases available lets
you track meal habits
visualize portion sizes and see calorie
density at a glance we're all strapped
for time
noom asks you to commit 10 minutes a day
for yourself you're human if you go off
track
there's no shaming just tips to help you
get back on track tomorrow what you need
is to
change your habits change your habits
you'll change it your health that's what
nume is for i've been using new myself
it's why i'm in a svelte shape at this
point go check them out right now for
your free trial at noom.com
shapiro sign up for that trial today
noom.com
shapironom.com shapiro to start
that trial today go check them out right
now nom.com
shapiro okay so florida
is it was a source of early excitement
for republicans last night as well
it should have been trump cultivated the
latino vote in florida and it paid off
reported in nbc
news last night around 55 percent of
florida's cuban-american vote went to
trump according to nbc news exit polls
30 to puerto ricans 48 of other latinos
backed trump trump won the state going
away
he drastically improved his support in
miami-dade county he went from 334 000
votes in 2016
to at least 529 000 votes in miami-dade
county
biden did not grow democratic support in
the county in other words
trump went places that people had not
gone he went to democratic counties and
he stumped for votes and he got those
votes
and all credit to my security guy in
florida who happens to be of latino
extraction he said
you're gonna be shocked by the amount of
turnout that you see for donald trump
and he was absolutely right it's one of
the reasons why i've been saying
for a couple weeks now that i think
trump is going to win florida trump's
popularity
meant that other house democrats fell
representative debbie mcassell powell is
the first south american member
south american born member of congress
she was trailing carlos jimenez the
miami-dade mayor
in her congressional race and
representative donogha is out
trailing tv host and commentator maria
elvira salazar
okay this is largely because democrats
have embraced the
mantle of socialism and it turns out
when you embrace the mantle of socialism
and you are attempting to gain ground
with crowds who have come from socialist
countries you know who doesn't like
socialism
everybody who's ever lived in a
socialist country you know who loves
socialism a bunch of white people who
don't live in socialist countries
that's the message of what happened in
florida trump outperformed with latinos
in florida
by a huge huge margin meanwhile
apparently
donald trump also outperformed with jews
in florida he won about 41
of the jews in florida which makes a lot
of sense he's the most pro-israel
president in american history bar none
okay that is a uh that's an amazing
showing
right and that is largely because the
jewish population in florida is either
old enough
that they are sort of traditional
jewishly and still care about the state
of israel
or they are orthodox or very big
orthodox community in
south florida which is one of the
reasons why i now live in south florida
okay so florida is a good indicator for
where the republican party is moving
going forward and there's a lot of talk
last night about building a
working-class party it's not just a
working-class party
with multi-ethnic appeal here is the
thing by making inroads with latinos i
mean there were stats from texas last
night that are absolutely astonishing
okay they're the the most latino
district in the united states
96 latino in texas it only went for
biden 52-47
52-47 those are heavy inroads into
a new demographic that republicans have
been told you could only win
if you cater to them on illegal
immigration and amnesty and it turns out
that's not true
because the vast major every single
latino who is voting in the united
states right now is legally in the
united states because you have to be in
order to vote
so it turns out all you have to do is go
and talk to people and trump does talk
to people he talks to them directly
that is a major victory for trump and
it's a lesson for any republican
going forward that is a very very
positive time for the republican party
going forward and
here's the thing if trump was
disproportionately bad with white
college-educated folks that mitt romney
won in 2012
imagine if you could capture the share
that mitt romney won
of white suburban women in 2012 and
combine that with the share that donald
trump is winning
of black and latino voters in 2020 that
is a majority party and that is a clear
majority party
that's an amazing amazing thing so good
on donald trump and good on the american
people
for spitting in the eye of the woke
now naturally this uh this was this a
lesson for the media
who really believed that they got to
declare the outcome of the election
three weeks in advance four weeks in
advance right the media who declared for
years the donald trump was an
illegitimate president the people hated
him so much
he would there's no way no way he would
even be competitive in this election
republicans were gonna get absolutely
hammered
swamped it was gonna be a hurricane that
blew them away
were the media repentant last night of
course the media weren't repentant last
night
are you kidding the media weren't
repentant not for one iota of a second
the daily show's reaction to trump
winning florida is they put out a meme
of the death star blowing up florida
here's what that sounded like
and you see the dust start blowing up
the state of florida they said can we do
this global florida
now i just put that out there when ted
cruz suggested that there's a difference
between new york values and texas values
he was accused of anti-semitism by the
left he was accused of being a bigot by
the left
the daily show just puts out there that
we should nuke florida basically
because you don't like florida and
that's supposed to be funny that's
supposed to be good funny stuff yeah
keep keep it going guys
more of this more of this because here's
the really deep down and dirty truth
about trump and his level of support
because people like me i didn't vote for
him in 2016. i voted for him
in florida in 2020 and i'll tell you why
the reason i voted for donald trump
maybe above all others is because what
donald trump
he said many things that i think are not
true he said one thing that is the most
true thing
that he's ever said which is they don't
hate you because they hate donald trump
they hate donald trump because they hate
you hey they
they hate you if you voted for donald
trump they hate you if you think
that the woke left is bad they hate you
they're willing to destroy you they're
willing to destroy your life
they're willing to use canceled culture
to come after your job they're willing
to ostracize you from every social
situation and declare you an
unmentionable
that is what they think of you they
think that if you voted for donald trump
you deserve to be nuked that's the way
it is okay and it's because of that that
so many people are saying you know what
i'm not going to listen to you i'm not
having that conversation with you
because you're not reasonable
you're not rational and so the media is
there going to be a reckoning in the
media
i highly doubt it i don't think there's
going to be a reckoning in the media not
for one second
they've already decided which direction
they're going to move
they're not going to abandon their
anti-racist imbacks candy robin deangelo
grift they're not going to give that up
any time soon they're going to keep
pushing
on that they're going to keep portraying
everyone who disagrees with them as
racist because they have only one mode
their pop star never stopped never
stopping they're never going to stop
with this sort of thing
so whether donald trump wins or loses
they've painted themselves in a corner
because guess what the reason the
democrats did so badly last night is due
to two factors
one donald trump has a unique connection
with folks and two
one of the reasons that donald trump has
a unique connection with folks is
because the left is egregious and
horrifying
because the woke left is egregious and
horrifying and terrible
in every way and they demonstrated at
full scale with a lot of their reactions
to what was going on
last night particularly on a racial
level we'll get to that in just one
second
first let's talk about how male pattern
baldness if it runs in your family you
need to protect your hair you really do
so male pattern baldness unfortunately
runs on both sides of my family and that
is why i have been using keeps as dudes
much of our identity is wrapped up in
our hair
from how it feels after getting a fresh
cut to the way it's styled before going
out that's why when we get into our 20s
and 30s
you start noticing the first signs of
hair loss you need to get active you
need to sign up with keeps because two
out of three dudes will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35 the best way to
prevent hair loss is to do something
about it while you still have the hair
left
get treated from home you used to have
to go to the doctor's office for your
hair loss prescription
now thanks to keeps you can visit a
doctor online and get hair loss
medication delivered
directly to your home they make it easy
they deliver your medication every three
months so you can say goodbye to
pharmacy checkout lines and awkward
doctor visits keeps offers generic
versions of the only two fda approved
hair loss products out there you might
have tried them before probably never
for this price keeps treatments
typically take between four to six
months to see results so you need to
act fast find out why keeps has more
five star reviews than any of its
competitors and more than a hundred
thousand men trust keeps including me
for their hair loss prevention
medication their treatment starts at
just 10 bucks a month if you're ready to
take action and prevent that hair loss
head on over to keeps.com
to receive your first month of treatment
for free that is k-e-e-p-s
dot com that is keeps dot com slash ben
all right we're gonna get to
much much more in just one second first
i mean
what an unbelievably tight race maybe
the tightest race in american history by
the electoral college
we we've kept you in the loop every step
of the way with all of yesterday's
coverage we'll keep you covered all the
way
till the end it's still too soon to tell
who exactly is going to be the president
will trump win re-election or will biden
slide on in there
join daily wear right now get 25 off
with code election right now you can
keep up with us on all the unfolding
twists and turns we're going to be here
with you pretty much
all day today not only that we have huge
plans for the next four years regardless
of who the president turns out to be i'm
happy to announce as we did
last night that candace owens new york
times bestselling author founder of the
blexit foundation single-handedly in
many ways responsible for a shift in the
black vote toward republicans
will be launching a brand new show with
us early next year in nashville she's
moving with us to nashville
she's also going to be writing content
for us over at dailywire.com
we're also going to be launching an
entertainment channel with like real
entertainment conservative oriented
entertainment we're not ignoring you the
way that netflix and amazon do a new
investigative journalism team we're
hiring up journalists to do the work the
mainstream
media will not they're too busy trying
to prevent the hundred biden story from
getting out
we're gonna build like-minded
partnerships with people like prageru
their entire show library will now be
available
to dailywire.com members by the end of
the year
again that's 25 off your daily wire
membership with code election when you
sign up today
because we are building we are building
the replacement media if there's one
thing 2020 has taught us it's that
anything can happen
including that we can actually make a
difference what you are doing is making
what we're doing is making a difference
and we have big plans we're going to
change the institutional structure of
the country
when it comes to entertainment when it
comes to culture we are we're going to
get into all of those things next year
we want you to join us
please go over and subscribe at daily
wire 25 off with code election when you
sign up today
also while you're at it you may have
noticed that these battles
for the future of the country are very
much pitched i mean these are these are
very contested battles if you want your
kids to know
about why america is great if you want
to know why there are people attacking
the greatness of america pick up a copy
of my book how to destroy america in
three easy steps it is worth the read is
more relevant today than it even was
yesterday because this battle is not
going to end
america is on a nice edge it's going to
remain on a knife's edge so long
as americans don't understand the roots
of their own values
it's time for them to be reacquainted go
pick up a copy of my book how to destroy
america in three easy steps right now
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so the amount of scorn that the
media have i don't think that ends so
there's a lot of talk after 2016 about
how we're going to go out we're going to
investigate the trump voter and then
within five minutes they were like you
know what it's easier to call trump a
racist
it's easier just to follow what he does
on twitter and call him a racist and you
know what that had no impact
none it's like not only none less than
none
because trump did pick up votes he did
he's gonna win a broader share of the
electorate
this time around than he did last time
around and whether or not he ends up
winning the election
and if you think that democrats are
simply going to abandon
their woke priorities you have another
think coming
okay they they are not i just have no
faith that they are going to
give up on the wokeness culture that
they have promulgated here nicole hannah
jones tweeted last night in the
aftermath of florida which again
florida was a devastating rebuttal to
the entire intersectional philosophy
latinos voting in outsized numbers for
donald trump 55
of cubans voting for trump a huge
percentage of latinos generally across
the country voting for trump he picked
up
hispanic women he picked up hispanic men
he picked a black man he picked up black
women
all of those numbers were up so
naturally nicole hannah jones the
in-house racist at the new york times
tweeted out one day after this election
is over i'm going to write a piece about
how latino
is a contrived ethnic category that
artificially lumps white cubans with
black puerto ricans and indigenous
guatemalans and helps explain why
latinos support trump at the second
highest rate
ah so you see you're not truly latino
unless you vote for democrats according
to nicole hannah jones just as you're
not truly black if you if you don't vote
for democrats according to nicole hannah
jones the racism is not going to stop
they cannot give up on this narrative
because they believe it is still their
pathway to power they don't want to make
the arguments on behalf of their own
policies their policies are not popular
so they are going to continue to rely
on this character assassination of
everybody who disagrees so now according
to nicole hannah jones
cubans are white did you know that
cubans are white now why because they
voted republican
and presumably as an increasing share of
venezuelans but republican they too will
become white
and the only people who will not be
white are the people who vote nicole
hannah jones
wants them to vote because in nicole
hannah jones's world the way that
she uses white as a stand-in for evil
and therefore if you are a cuban and you
voted for trump
you are evil thus you are white this is
pure unbridled racism
that's the lady who founded the 1619
project and is the de facto editor
of the new york times she wasn't the
only person to say
nonsense like this there's a person
last night named andrea pino silva
who is a movement scholar author and
queer kubana
she tweeted out the cuban vote is not
the latino vote cubans have been sold to
narrative that they have a guaranteed
path to whiteness and many will sell out
every other minority to get it
trump's appeal is the appeal of white
supremacy doesn't matter he
won an increased share of black voters
doesn't matter he won an inquiry share
of latino voters
none of that matters the only thing that
matters is that if you voted for trump
it is because you are a it is because
you are a
vicious brutal racist al sharpton
another vicious racist who has a slot
over on msnbc he said this last night
he said the cuban voters are just stupid
that's what happened human voters bought
the socialist propaganda
that joe biden and kamala harris were
socialist okay well it turns out that
they bought into it because democrats
have embraced that label
bernie sanders calls himself a socialist
democrats
call themselves progressives which in
many
south and latin american countries is a
synonym for socialist
that is their fault but here's al
sharpton pretending that cubans are just
stupid that's why they're voting for
trump
we don't have the same dynamics that we
have in florida
where you have like in miami-dade i
think it was joy pointing out a large
cuban influence uh in terms of cuban
voters
who look more uh uh to the propaganda
that
we're dealing with socialism and all
that offset a large black turnout
okay so again it's all about it's all
about the supposed
whiteness problem okay arn duncan the
former education secretary and a barack
obama tweeted out last night we should
stop talking about red and blue we
should start talking about whiteness
they're not gonna let go of this not in
any way shape or form so if you think
your media are gonna suddenly learn a
lesson
wrong you are the same media who have
been lying to you and honestly i don't
know how to read the polls being this
wrong nationally
except that these people either are in
such a deep bubble that they have
internalized their own inability
to pull trump voters and then pretended
that they live in a universe of their
own making
or this was a lot of push pulling right
there's a lot of polling that was
designed to disintegrate trump's support
particularly
in battleground states by saying that
states like wisconsin and michigan were
out of reach
okay but the media are not going to
shift their story the media have a
narrative the media have an agenda
and we need to replace them the media
were worth
a minimum of five to ten points for joe
biden in this election if we're not for
the media that is a minimum
if it were not for the media if the
media had covered donald trump honestly
if the media had covered politics
honestly
if the media weren't damned liars in
pursuit of an agenda donald trump would
have won easily last night
easily because even if donald trump
loses we're going to be talking about
donald trump losing
by a combined total of probably under
100 000 votes in pennsylvania
michigan wisconsin and arizona and
nevada
right this is it's an extraordinarily
close election
the media sort of let the cat out it's
fun to watch the media rewrite the
narrative in real time it's a bad night
for the media last night
you could see they were downcast about
all of this obviously the most fun
person to watch was chang geiger over at
the young turks he just lost it chang
geiger
um now to be fair chank is a an opinion
host he is not an objective journalist
we'll get to our objective journalism
friends we're journalism all over the
place
the journalism was hot and sticky last
night all over cnn and msnbc
but we would be remiss if we did not
play chank losing his mind last night
forget him being a racist forget him
being a fascist
the guy's iq is lower than 70. he's an
idiot he's a total and you
couldn't figure out how to
crush him in an election man the
corporate democrats in the mainstream
media
suck at this they absolutely positively
suck
and they brainwash smart people into
compliance
okay so um he's right about the
mainstream media brainwashing people
into compliance he's just
hilariously wrong about the idea that if
the democrats attacked way to the left
they would have done better in this
election
okay they the only reason that they were
even competitive in this election is
they ran
a dead man who was a vessel for all
anti-trump sentiment in the country
imagine how bad this would have been if
bernie sanders said one trump wins going
away right
i mean given these results if bernie
sanders had been on the ballot
this thing is over early in the night
for trump okay but let's go to the
objective media so watch as the
narrative shifted last night
uh in the objective media so jake tapper
on cnn said a biden blowout was always a
pipe dream was it though
because i'm old enough to remember
because i'm more than one day old when
the entire media was declaring
that there was a 90 shot that biden was
going to win because he was going to
blow out trump
right that the national polling was
showing that he was up 7 to 10 points so
here is jake tapper now rewriting
the story so that biden blowout was
apparently always
a pipe dream the biden people we should
say have not conceded any
florida or georgia or north carolina and
they feel very good
uh they still feel good about north
carolina they still feel very
very positive about arizona and the blue
wall but it's just not going to be as
some democrats were hoping for
uh that they thought it was going to be
an earl an early landslide
which was really always a pipe dream
okay well why
why was that a pipe dream i mean
seriously we were told that that was
actually not a pipe dream that was a
heavy possibility by many members
of the media not jake specifically i
assume but many many members of the
media were saying that
it was a foregone conclusion that biden
was going to blow out trump trump was
going to lose north carolina he was
going to lose florida he's going to lose
them early and the night was going to be
over by 7 p.m
pacific time okay brian williams let the
cat out of the bag he was like yeah
the numbers so far been frustrating for
our viewers yeah you're damn right
they're frustrating for your viewers
because they're a bunch of liberal
partisans
we are coming up on to the top of the
hour we are
at the point where there's not many poll
closings left but
there are a few particularly as we get
to the west coast and there are a number
of states left
[Music]
and boy does um do some of the numbers
start to
add up as we get late in the night
however
frustrating this night is for many many
of our viewers
yep it is very frustrating for many of
the of the msnbc viewers because it did
not go how they wanted van jones
was extremely upset last night at the
results he lost it he says this just
hurts it just hurts
there's a moral victory and there's a
political victory no they're not the
same thing
the political victory still may come but
i think for people who saw
babies being snatched away from their
mothers at the border
for people who are sending their kids
into schools where the n-word is now
being used against them
people have seen this wave of
intolerance they wanted a moral victory
tonight
we wanted to see a repudiation
of this direction for the country and
the fact that it's this close i think
uh is hurt it hurts it just hurts
okay and it does hurt members of the
media because they had a narrative and
the media completely impli
it imploded on them in the middle of the
night i will say it was kind of
wonderful to watch george stephanopoulos
enter into an arena of panic so george
stephanopoulos last night
i began to lose it in the middle of the
night it was kind of funny
it may be a little early to start to
pull out narratives but rob emanuel
let's try to do a little bit this is
looking a little bit right now
like a replay of 2016. well i'm not sure
the problem we have is you have so much
early voting
and every state is different of when
they count that and so we're looking at
counties
and you can extrapolate when you look at
how close ohio is it's basically six
percent right now
better than it was in 2016. but you look
at i think it's still going to come down
to
pennsylvania okay and you could see the
panic in democrats eyes
all throughout the evening are they
going to shift because of this because
they got this so wrong
there are a lot of tweets this morning
from a lot of folks on the
center left about how they need to
rethink how they've framed american
politics
you think they will i really really
think not i really really think not i
i don't think that's going to happen
okay so where do things currently stand
so the current update is that wisconsin
has told nbc news that they are done
counting that biden has won
wisconsin nevada is not done yet nevada
has
biden up by about 8 000 10 000 votes but
they're not resuming until tomorrow
arizona was called for biden last night
but republicans keep insisting that
arizona is still open i've talked to
trump campaign operatives who say
that the final account in arizona is
going to be a lot closer than what they
are talking about
right now at the very least apparently
biden is up in michigan right now but
trump is up in pennsylvania
as well as georgia so this thing is
still very much
up in the air and that is putting aside
any and all legal challenges that could
be brought
it's putting aside mandatory recounts in
wisconsin if they're within margin of
error there's a mandatory recount
you know all of this is still a mess so
could trump still win it
sure does he have an uphill path at this
point he does have an uphill path
right it would be nice if he had won
arizona if he'd won arizona then this
election would basically be over at this
point right if he won arizona
then he would win pennsylvania and then
this sucker would be done okay so last
night
joe biden came out and uh and he
suggested that they were on track to win
the election here was joe biden's
statement this is very very late last
night
we believe we're on track to win this
election
[Applause]
we knew because of the unprecedented
early vote in a mail-in vote
that's going to take a while we're going
to have to be patient
until we uh the hard work of italian
votes is finished
and it ain't over until every vote is
counted every ballot is counted
okay so there he was saying that he
expects that they're going to win then
president trump came out last night
uh and he gave a statement he did a much
more uh
a much more comprehensive statement on
the on the vote so first he tweeted out
uh that he they were winning big he said
we are up big but they are trying to
steal the election
we'll never let them do it votes cannot
be cast after the polls are closed
presumably there he's talking about
pennsylvania
right that uh he says we're up big and
they're trying to steal the election
okay at the time
they were up big in the vote count right
i mean that's not false it doesn't
matter twitter tried to
dispute the tweet and said that it was
irresponsible and all the rest
because this is twitter's mandate
twitter is now the the arbiter of all
truth
and what he's talking about there is the
pennsylvania
state rules that do not make it clear
whether or not you can count a vote that
has been cast
after election day even if it has no
postmark right that is what he's talking
about there presumably okay so last
night
trump comes out and he says he looks a
little bit downcast because i think he
wanted to walk away with the victory
on the night of obviously he says we're
winning pennsylvania
most importantly we're winning
pennsylvania by a tremendous amount of
we're up 690 000 votes in pennsylvania
000 these aren't even close
it's not like oh it's close
with 64 percent of the
vote end it's going to be almost
impossible to catch and we're coming
into
good pennsylvania areas where they
happen to like
your president because he said that he
said that about that that analysis of
pennsylvania may very well end up being
right
trump may end up winning pennsylvania
then trump says that in his opinion
they've already won the election
uh which of course is a step beyond what
biden said so what biden said was
i think we're on a path to win the
election which is an opinion
trump says we did win the election uh is
uh
is an overstatement right and he
shouldn't say it right is the president
of the united states
you should wait for the vote to be
counted and then declare victory you
shouldn't declare victory in an election
or the votes yet to be counted
so he says two things as we will see one
of them is not good and you shouldn't
have said it
the other is being wildly misinterpreted
by the media for political purposes
so here was president trump talking
about how in his opinion the election's
already been won by trump
north carolina big victory with north
carolina
and so we won there we lead by
76 000 votes with almost nothing left
and all of a sudden everything just
stopped
this is a fraud on the american public
this is an embarrassment to our country
we were getting ready to win this
election
frankly we did win this election okay so
that statement that we won the election
and there's fraud happening all over the
country see the responsible statement
there
is we have lawyers on the ground in all
of these states to ensure that fraud is
not going to be the deciding factor
in this election we believe that we're
on a pathway to victory in fact that's
exactly what mike pence said one moment
later so
that is something that that president
trump should obviously not have said
then president trump said at one point i
want to find the direct quote
because people were taking it out of
context so president trump was talking
about the vote and he uh and he he said
so here was a statement from the biden
campaign manager okay they said the
president's statement tonight about
trying to shut down the counting of duly
cast ballots was outrageous
unprecedented and incorrect that's not
what trump said
trump did not said they should stop
counting duly counted ballots or dually
cast bats he says
we want all voting to stop we don't want
them to find any ballots at four o'clock
in the morning and add them to the list
okay
now we want all vote counting to stop in
fact trump was protesting the fact that
there were random stoppages of the vote
counting last night
right there was this this weird two-hour
gap where all of a sudden all the states
kind of stopped at once
stopped reporting ongoing election
counting results and started reporting
them reporting them in bulk when trump
said we want all voting to stop we don't
want them to find ballots at four
o'clock in the morning and add them to
the list
he's clearly saying we don't actually
want them to manufacture votes in the
middle of the night
and then use that to make up the margins
so
that's not wrong i mean it isn't so he
said two things they're one of them is
not great
one of them is fine the media are
treating both of them as the end of the
world obviously
here's the bottom line this election
will end with some form of litigation in
some of these states there will be some
recounts in some of the states we're
going to find out
in shorter order rather than longer or
where things stand but if you're a
conservative
if you're a conservative i know
everybody's on tensorflow's about the
presidential i am too
i mean everybody's got a turning in the
gut i do too i get it we're going to be
here all day bringing you updates and
all day tomorrow and as long as this
thing goes
but if you're a conservative you should
be looking at the outcome of last
night's election given
the priors and think to yourself that
was a massive victory
a massive victory against the hard
radical left and that is a great thing
that every
everybody should be celebrating right
now you are allowed to take a sip of
champagne
for how the election went last night
even while we wait for the final outcome
of the presidential all right we'll be
back here later today with two
additional hours of content including
all of the updates i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam sci events
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nico geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 20 20. these are
the times that try men's souls the
summer soldier and the sunshine patriot
will
in this crisis shrink from the service
of their country
but he that stands by it now deserves
the love
and thanks of man and woman we've got
the latest on the election check it out
on the michael knowles show